la mayoría de los líquidos se contraen
al enfriarse el agua por otro lado se
expande al congelarse su volumen
incrementa en un 9% supongamos que
tenemos un tercio de un litro de agua
que vamos a congelar cuál será el
volumen de hielo que vamos a obtener
expresa tu respuesta como una fracción
entonces vamos a empezar a escribir
nuestro problema tenemos
un tercio de litro de agua tenemos un
tercio este de aquí
es nuestro volumen original
y nos están diciendo que al congelarse
se expande en un 9% entonces tendremos
que sumar
un 9%
del volumen original o sea 9% veces un
tercio
y bien esto es lo que tenemos que
resolver existen infinidad de maneras
para resolver esta expresión que tenemos
aquí por ejemplo podríamos convertirlo a
decimales o podríamos utilizar una
calculadora en fin existen diferentes
maneras de resolver esta expresión nos
están pidiendo que expresemos la
respuesta como una fracción así que
observemos todo lo que tenemos aquí son
fracciones pues no efectivamente hay una
parte que tendremos que convertir a
fracciones que es el 9% entonces a ver
esto será igual a un tercio es el
volumen original y ahora como reescribo
9% en fracciones bueno que es 9% a ver
usemos otro color entonces
el 9% lo voy a escribir como fracción 9%
lo puedo escribir bueno hay un tercio le
voy a sumar
el 9 por ciento que son 9 centésimos
9 centésimos estaba multiplicando a un
tercio
bien vamos mejorando vamos a seguir
trabajando con esta expresión entonces
ahora tengo que esto es igual a un
tercio que es el volumen original muy
bien y ahora tengo este producto de dos
fracciones observamos que al 9 lo puedo
escribir en términos de 3 19 es tres por
tres entonces aquí 13 se cancela con
este 3 que está aquí y solo me queda un
entonces la multiplicación de fracciones
me va a quedar
de la siguiente manera aquí arriba me
queda 3 por 1 que es 3 y abajo el 3
desapareció solo me queda un 100
muy bien y esto que es igual bien pues
ahora tenemos que sumar dos fracciones
que tienen denominador distinto entonces
tenemos que encontrar un denominador
común pero observamos que 3 y 100 pues
no tienen factores comunes el mínimo
común múltiplo
será el producto de los dos y
obtendremos fracciones con denominador
300 el primer término me quedara como
dijimos en la parte de abajo hay un 300
y si multiplique por 100 el denominador
tengo que hacerlo con el numerador y
entonces obtengo 100
cien por uno es 100 y ahora vamos con el
siguiente término
necesito que en el denominador tenga un
en este término si al denominador lo
multiplique por tres para obtener 300 al
numerador tendré que multiplicarlo por
tres y tres por tres es 9
y ahora ya podemos sumar porque ya
tenemos dos fracciones con el mismo
denominador entonces 100 más 9 es 109 y
el denominador es 300 y ya tenemos
nuestra respuesta expresada como una
fracción